dunning the right-hander era just a
little bit above four good number of
strikeouts 111 and 114 innings pretty
solid opponent's batting average mile
straw leads it off
and a base hit in a right field for mile
straw
and boy how appropriate is that the way
he has swung the bat coming down the
stretch and using right field
runner goes and an easy steal for mile
straw he hangs onto the bag with his
foot and his 30th stolen base of the
season now the batter ahmed rosario
right back up the middle and it gets
through file straw around third he will
score and the indians take a one-nothing
lead that didn't take long
but that stayed on the inside part of
the plate but he takes it right back up
the middle aaron savali trying to finish
this season off on on a good note he's
been very good this year on the road
he's six and one with a 332 let's hope
he can go out there and be the air and
savali like we know
for anybody really
left field long run for mercado and he
runs it down and the rangers go one two
three
it's one nothing cleveland after an
inning here's dj peters the right-handed
hitting center fielder the pitch
and strike three called looking at the
cut fastball
so aaron savali has made 10 pitches
in each of the first two innings tribe
one rangers nothing ahmed rosario leads
off the third
ahmed rosario draws a lead off walk and
up comes jose ramirez well i can
guarantee you one thing oh how about
that perfectly placed off the glove and
into right field and jose's gonna keep
on going the throw not in time
that first hustle slide
that's how you get doubles
that one off the glove of dunning
oh it goes away all the way to the top
and scoring is rosario
ramirez to third it's two nothing
cleveland on the wild pitch two balls
two strikes one more time to reyes and a
swing and a miss he gets him swinging
his first strikeout this afternoon went
away here comes the 2-2
and that pitch on the outside corner for
a called third strike fastball gets
chang looking
second out here in the top half of the
third two nothing tribe runner third two
down zimmer who grounded out his first
time the pitch
swung on grounded back up the middle
base hit into right center ramirez
scores bradley zimmer makes it a
three-nothing ball game left leaves it
away it was and he takes advantage of it
left it up a little bit oscar mercado
reached on an air his first time up and
the pitch now too mercado runner goes
it's outside zimmer has an uncontested
steal
mercato yanks what deep left field it is
one hop defense it's a ground rule
double that'll get another run home as
zimmer scores
they've played three here in the third
and lead it four to nothing well there
comes a little two-seam fastball down
and in and he smoked it
crown rolled double bounces into the
seats
the second straight two out hit by the
indians
there's a swing and a miss he hasn't
thrown 80 pitches in a game since june
rangers have limited him all year and
that might well have been his last
of the season he strikes out
austin hedges the ending is done but
cleveland leads four nothing it'll be
solac
jose trevino and yani hernandez
and he hits this one up the middle you
can make it seven of his last eight
solak has the rangers first hit for the
ball game here comes jose trevino now
who has been nicked up with foul balls
and the two strike pitches hit on the
right side right in front of solace and
into right field of base head zimmer up
with it he'll fire it back into second
that's where solak stops so trevino on
an o2 pitch shoots this one the other
way and he'll finish the season having
hit safely in each of his last six
assignments
[Music]
swung out and missed he got him to swing
over the top of that breaking ball
second strikeout for savali
here's the set from savali
the pitch
swing and a miss
low down on strikes
that's the third for aaron savali
two down here in the fourth
and that brings up andy ibanya
here's a hard hit ball through on the
left side a base hit for andy bunya
right now where is 0 for two here's the
pitch and reyes takes it outside for
ball four a four pitch walk
at the plate here comes the pitch swung
on and there's a high drive this one
headed to deep left field way back there
and it hits the top of the wall and goes
out a home run
a wall scraper for you chang but it
counts home run chang
and the indians are now up six nothing
chang hit it to dead left
and it hit the top of the wall right on
the yellow line and kept right on going
on the ricochet
and for you chang home run number nine
gives the indians a six-run lead as
bradley zimmer steps in the pitch swung
on line drive pace it anyway
right near where they shifted away from
and zimmer went right there fulton must
be thinking come on guys i stopped my
motion for that savali from the stretch
here's the o2 and it's a called strike
three he poured the fastball right in
there and hernandez took it for a false
strike bush a chance now to pitch in the
final game of the season
and a swing and a miss
bush gets a strikeout gotta love that
well it's definitely not a fluke
he's throwing 96 miles an hour with a
sharp breaking curveball looks like a
strike and then
drops out of the strike zone nick has
been on board twice today he singled the
left center in the third and then drew a
walk and was stranded in the fifth
inning
this one on the ground and that one gets
through base hit for solac he's on for
the third time today
his second hit to go with the watch
class a will finish it up for the
indians
and what a season he's had as a rookie
he should get a lot of votes for
american league rookie of the year
round ball to short ahmed rosario
throws him out one down here's pitch
number 10
and nate lowe swings and misses two down
what a battle clause wins it this at bat
and the pitches that he was seeing as
seen in it the pitch as he fouled off
that's one he won't forget and he comes
back with that low dart again incredible
the pitch swung on lifted shallow right
zimmer coming on he'll make the catch
ball game and season over
the indians today
blank
the texas rangers by a final score of
six to nothing
they'll end the campaign with a record
of 80 and 82 today is officially the
last game that we will talk about this
being the cleveland indians we all know
that the indians name will now go away
and it'll be the cleveland guardians
you